following contact with the mayor of
london today
it is quite clear that the mayor no
longer has sufficient confidence in my
leadership
of the metropolitan police service
for me to continue as commissioner
he has left me no choice but to step
aside
i say this with deep sadness
and regret
at his request i have agreed to stay on
for
a short period a number of weeks
to ensure the stability of the met
and its leadership
while necessary arrangements
can be made for a transition to a new
commissioner
undertaking this role
a crown appointment
as a servant of the people of london
and the united kingdom
has been the greatest honor and
privilege of my life
throughout my career i have sought to
protect the people
of this wonderful thriving
and diverse city
there have been many tough calls
and many challenges
the 2017 terrorist attacks
the grenfell fire
very difficult protests the pandemic
the murder of serving officers
i'm incredibly proud of my team and all
that they have achieved